did you close the deal with Taraji P
Henson that night
who was like you guys were together I
didn't know you were with her
well look you got a uh that's a serious
resume that uh Lamar Odom's got in life
I've been in La since I was 19. man
what about like back in the day before
there's only fans before there's IG
chicks there was like the chicks who
would make it on like King Magazine
right like the glory of alez's uh what
was that one girl what's the
Rose now before her the Vita Guerra well
you know what those crazy about that
like
I think because of who uh because of who
I am where I live at
I have really access to
everybody right I was I wasn't out like
looking for somebody yo when I see him
if I bump the tour or whatever and I got
to kick her to her yeah whatever you
know what I mean but I wasn't out like
yo if I see this one I wasn't out yo let
me send this one a message to my manager
[ __ ] like that I'll move like that right
but some guys do that right they'll
sound like they'll send their guy to go
have all the especially nowadays you
can't hit a girl up directly you'll be
on hold the IG and [ __ ] like that right
yeah they'll just screenshot it every
time I hit a girl actually I'd be like
let me watch my verbiage you got to be
careful let me know what I'm saying let
me don't sound too thirsty or too
aggressive because
and get flip it definitely could get